Zehn Billiarden Tonnen!
Das ist eine echt unfassbare Zahl!
Und tatsächlich hat ein Forschungsteam vom
renommierten Massachusetts Institute of Technology
(MIT) jetzt herausgefunden, dass die Erde
in ihrem Inneren mehr als zehn Billiarden
Tonnen Diamanten verbergen könnte.
Tausendfach mehr als bisher gedacht - und
das überrascht auch die Wissenschaftswelt
extrem.
Ein riesiger Schatz in der Tiefe also - direkt
unter unseren Füßen - wow!
Wie kommen wir also ran?
Clixoom Science & Fiction, Hier gibt es täglich
faszinierende Wissenschaftsvideos.
Abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts. herzlich willkommen!
Diamanten begeistern uns Menschen schon seit
langer Zeit: Als Edelsteine sind sie kostbar
und sehr beliebt.
Für einen Rohdiamanten aus Afrika gab es
bei einer Versteigerung erst vor kurzem satte
40 Millionen Dollar.
Doch rein wissenschaftlich gesehen handelt
es sich bei Diamanten einfach “nur” um
Kohlenstoff, der unter hohem Druck und unter
Hitze komprimiert wurden.
Damit sind sie der härteste natürliche Stoff
der Welt.
Urzeitliche Vulkane haben sie dann irgendwann
einmal aus der Tiefe des Erdmantels nach oben
befördert und für uns Menschen zugänglich
gemacht.
Meistens entstehen sie in bis zu 200 Kilometer
Tiefe und die besonders Großen unter ihnen
sogar noch tiefer in der Erde.
Konkret entstehen Diamanten in den sogenannten
Kratonen.
Das sind die quasi die Kontinent-Wurzeln,
die rund 300 Kilometer in den Erdmantel hineinragen.
Ihr könnt sie Euch vorstellen wie umgekehrte
Berge, die tief in den Erdmantel hineinreichen.
Es sind die ältesten und unbeweglichsten
Gesteinsschichten, die unter dem Zentrum der
meisten Kontinentalplatten liegen.
Um die Spitzen der Kratone ging es auch dem
Forschungsteam des Massachusetts Institute
of Technology.
Denn wenn seismische Wellen diese Kraton-Wurzeln
passieren, werden sie immer schneller - rund
4,7 Kilometer pro Sekunde.
Doch dieses hohe Tempo lässt sich seltsamerweise
nicht mit den dort vorhandenen Gesteins-Komponenten
erklären.
Ein großes Rätsel also für die Fachwelt!
Kurz zum Hintergrund: Prinzipiell können
seismische Empfänger auf der ganzen Welt
Wellen aufzeichnen, die durch Tsunamis, Explosionen
oder Erdbeben entstehen.
Die Wellen sind unterschiedlich schnell - je
nach Zusammensetzung, Dichte und Temperatur
des Gesteins, durch das sie sich bewegen.
Umgekehrt können Forschungsteams aber eben
auch durch das Tempo der Wellen rekonstruieren,
welche Art Gestein die Wellen passiert haben
müssen.
In ihrer Studie haben die US-Wissenschaftler
und -Wissenschaftlerinnen seismische Messdaten
mit einem virtuellen Experiment verknüpft.
Sie erstellten virtuelle Kratonwurzeln und
analysierten in einer Simulation, wie schnell
sich Bebenwellen sich dort fortbewegungen.
Und zwar je nachdem, welche Testgesteine sie
in ihrem Modell eingesetzt hatten.
Ihr Ergebnis: Die Kratonwurzel besteht zu
knapp 80 Prozent aus dem Gestein Peridotit
und zu 20 Prozent aus Eklogit.
Dabei handelt es sich um ein basaltisches
Umwandlungsgestein.
Zudem gab es aber die riesige Überraschung:
Ein bis zwei Prozent der Kratonwurzel müssen
auch Diamant enthalten.
Das sind umgerechnet wohl mehr als zehn Billiarden
Tonnen!
Und das ist - wie gesagt - tausendfach mehr
als man bislang dachte.
Dazu einer der beteiligten Forscher, Ulrich
Faul, vom MIT: "Das ist zwar nur ein Indizienbeweis,
aber wir sind alle Möglichkeiten durchgegangen-
und dies ist das einzige, das als plausible
Erklärung übrig geblieben ist”.
Der Gehalt von ein bis zwei Prozent Diamant
passe nicht nur zu den geologischen Parametern,
sondern erkläre auch das hohe Tempo der Scherwellen.
Diese Erkenntnis ist tatsächlich neu und
zeigt uns, dass Diamanten gar nicht so selten
sind, wie häufig angenommen.
Allerdings nur geologisch gesehen.
Denn eine Möglichkeit, diesen Schatz zu erreichen,
gibt es nicht.
Das große Problem dabei: Die Diamanten liegen
bis zu 240 Kilometer tief unter der Erdoberfläche
- und das können selbst die tiefsten Bohrungen
nicht leisten. 1994 hatte man mit einem Rollenbohrmeisel
rund 9100 Meter geschafft - Weltrekord, was
ein derart senkrechtes tiefes Loch in die
Erdkruste angeht.
Kornkreise im Meer.
Was steckt dahinter.
Draufklicken, anschauen und die Neugierzone
abonnieren.
Bis dann, bleibt dran.